le vérificateur général qui a finalement
déposé son rapport et il accuse le
gouvernement de parfaits mais quoi
d'avoir des lunettes roses
on écoute c'est raisonnable c'est
correct
aucun nom qu'une et rabat ce n'est pas
exactement le constat du vérificateur
général sur la mise à jour économique de
novembre
les documents remis par le ministère
décrivent un processus rigoureux
si les prévisions économiques et celle
des revenus sont acceptables
celle sur les dépenses soulève de grosse
interrogation c'est que la croissance
prévue est d'environ 2% pour les
prochaines années alors qu'elle était en
moyenne de 4,6 pour cent au cours des
dernières années les sacrifices exigés
en santé et en éducation risque d'être
important en 2012 2013 ce taux de
croissance était de 4.1 pour ça dans les
deux réseaux
donc l'on prévoit en 2014 2015 1.1 pour
ça donc la marge est grande
ajoutez à cela un manque à gagner évalué
à deux milliards et demi d'ici deux ans
atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire
pourrait donc exigé des compressions
on pourrait dire on augmente la
tarification de certains services vous
avez sûrement des idées en tête com -
nicolas marceau refuse de dire comment
on pourra limiter la croissance des
dépenses en santé à seulement 1 %
voudraient vous répondre parfaitement
correctement cette question le et demain
je vais être plus en mesure de vous
répondre et cela pour les libéraux ce
rapport confirme le scénario du pire une
commande minimale au moins de deux
milliards de dollars de coupes de
compressions dans les services publics
et libéraux comme cas qu'est ce que
veulent savoir comment le gouvernement
va équilibrer les finances dans le
budget de juin
moi je peux bien vous dis demain matin
on restera en à val d'or et 10 pièces de
gaz mais je dirais pot commun
c'est tellement niveau froid que mame
awa nous donne un petit peu
d'explications en matière de finance
publique le casse tête de ce
gouvernement ou du prochain reste entier
le vérificateur général précise que
toute réduction des dépenses entraînera
inévitablement un certain ralentissement
la croissance économique
david gêne-t-il radio canada québec